i felt like the need to do more right to
give back to do more
but um what i saw the problem was is
that
we were getting rid of skills over here
right and then trying to hire these
unicorns over here
and i truly believed there was a better
way i bet
i believe that we could take the skills
and capabilities and knowledge of the
organization
and upskill into it welcome to 20-minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
today we're going to talk about the
milwaukee region
and we're honored with kathy hanrich the
ceo of the milwaukee tech up coalition
and non-profit focused on inclusively
doubling tech talent in the milwaukee
region
kathy is a long-term tech executive
leading sales and partnerships for over
500 million dollars in businesses and
hardware software and services
after receiving her master's in
workforce and town development
specifically in response to aion
automation
kathy helped large multinational
organizations transform their talent in
alignment
with their digital transformation kathy
also serves on multiple non-profit
boards in the milwaukee region
kathy henrich thank you for joining me
how are you
[Music]
i'm doing great thanks for having me
today thank you for joining me are you
talking from milwaukee right now
i am in the milwaukee area so and it is
beautiful here we've had
80 degree weather in early may so that's
fantastic
wonderful i believe this is the first
time in over 400 episodes of the show
that i've had somebody from wisconsin
dial in
and so i'm really excited to learn more
about the milwaukee region but also
specifically about the tech scene
and your work uh over there to to give
to to make space and and provide for the
for the talent
needs uh and and i think that there's a
lot of really interesting
things to learn from your experience
over there but what i'm also excited
about is going back
through your experiences either at ibm
and accenture and
some of the things that you've learned
and experience that that you're taking
with you now as you approach this new
challenge so kathy who are you
how how do you get started in all this
tech scene how do you get started with
ibm
where does it all begin
well so that's a long time ago but um i
actually i really wanted to work for ibm
um i was a non-technical major um
in fact i did not even have math or
science in
college i had tested out of it um
however apparently i had competencies
because i tested into
ibm and actually eventually became a
systems
programmer so this marketing major
learned enough to be able to do systems
programming and i think it probably does
shape
my view in that anybody right can learn
a technical content
if there is a basic competency and a
desire to learn
and so i really truly um think that
shapes probably some of my thinking wow
and and so
but um you know that's a long time ago
but more recently i came to the
coalition
about a year ago um and it's a
non-profit focused on inclusively
doubling tech talent in the milwaukee
region
and the reason um what led me here is
actually pretty interesting about
almost 30 years into my career with ibm
after having led half billion dollar
businesses
i actually did a crazy thing i um
i went and took a leave of absence and
got my masters in workforce and talent
development
um specifically focused on ai and
automation and the changing nature of
work
and the reason i
yeah the crazy thing is um
well i felt number one i felt like the
need to do more
right to give back to do more but um
what i saw the problem was
is that we were getting rid of skills
over here
right and then trying to hire these
unicorns over here
and i truly believed there was a better
way i bet i believe that we could take
the skills and capabilities and
knowledge of the organization
and upskill into it um and so i went
back into school and
that led me to actually going to
accenture
to help individual corporations as they
went through digital transformation
to transform their talent along with
that and um
ultimately led here after having done
some volunteer work for the coalition
as it was set up as a formal nonprofit
so you're spending
all this time at ibm getting your
masters
accenture future of work with ai and the
digital transformations that are coming
with
it and how do you find yourself then
because at that point you can choose to
dedicate your time
in a variety of ways and you choose to
join the milwaukee tech hub coalition
and that has a very strong purpose
especially in
in the region what was it that told you
this is one of the this is what i want
to focus on
well i've always been personally moted
by the ability to have an
impact and i found that
at accenture i was making an impact one
organization
at a time but if you think about making
an impact with
you know a million person metro i can
have a much bigger impact here
so that's why i did it and um enjoying
every minute of it
and so tell me a little bit about this
this tech hub coalition
and first let's start with with a pain
point so why why do we even need the
milwaukee tech up coalition to start
with
yeah so it's really interesting um it
was started actually by
six initial founding organizations and
the reason they did
is that um similar to many cities around
the country they were having difficulty
acquiring the amount of talent required
in order to fuel
their future which is all tech enabled
right
and so and you know they started with
some research etc the research says
that you know first of all we have about
80 000 tech
employees already in the milwaukee
region um
and of that we think with
you know natural attrition and
retirements
that there could be a gap of about 31
jobs or individuals to fill the the
necessary jobs
by the 2025 timeline so that's the
problem statement
is that we know that there is a shortage
um not only regionally but nationally
and internationally on having sufficient
tech talent
to be able to fuel the transformation
that we're under right now
right and so when you're looking at this
problem
how do you even go about strategizing
how do you go about even thinking
do i bring people in from the outside do
i raise them
in house how do you even approach this
problem of acquiring
talent for this region
you know it's an interesting thing
because as i came in um there had been
some work
that had been done and and i um
it took a lot of conversations and i
remember this moment
i was sitting in a meeting and somebody
talked about supply and demand i'm like
got it and so we actually think about it
in terms of
how do i drive demand for jobs um and
that includes the image of the region
it includes um a star a robust startup
ecosystem
and it includes the acquisition and
growth of tech companies here to the
region
while at the same time matching that
with the appropriate supply
and that comes through initiatives
around k-20
re-skilling and the attraction and
retention of individuals
and then there's this whole well there's
a lot of stuff going on right so
it became really a swot analysis of our
strengths weaknesses and gaps etc to
figure out
where we could amplify the work that was
already going on within the region and
what gaps needed to be filled in order
to
bring this forward so in each of those
areas
one of the things we're very fortunate
to have is
we've gone from those six initial
founding members in a year and a half to
75 organizations
who are all collaborating with us and
providing us insights and guidance
on where those gaps exist so that we can
start to fulfill those and and build the
momentum
in the region so what i really love you
know as young entrepreneur
is to to learn a little bit about
strategy and how one goes through
thinking of the different verticals that
you're choosing to to make this work you
mentioned k to 12
reskilling and up skilling so so or k to
20 sorry
so what is that what do those actually
mean how do you actually go and
tangibly you know make an impact with
those ideas in the region let's say with
with k to 20.
what does that mean yeah yeah you know
and
because we have such an immediate need
we focused on kind of the near
near employability so think about junior
high school and above
and one of the areas that we saw a gap
was um
well a part of it came out of covid um
because
early in covid a lot of internships were
being cancelled
and so we stepped up as a coveted
response and quickly put together in a
six-week time frame
we put together uh an internship program
in collaboration with another partner
here in the region
and we had in six weeks we had 700
applicants we had 120 students go
through this summer program
and through that we actually learned a
lot we learned a lot about what
employers need and we also learned about
what we could do collectively that we
couldn't do individually as
organizations
and we found really a gap around a
pre-internship
where students are getting ready for
those
in-person incorporation kinds of
internships
to get them ready and so this summer
we're actually doing a program
around the ethics and use of data in ai
for the students but everything we do we
believe is connected right
and so we actually have um educator
workshops that go along that so that you
can extend the impact
both for that individual but beyond that
individual in the pre-internship program
but then also career connections the
whole idea is you want these
interns getting hired right so having a
career connection as well
so we look at things very holistically
those are the
i'll call splashy things those hit the
newspaper
then there's the whole set of things
that never do right it's the
creation of an ecosystem and helping
school districts go through strategic
planning so that they can
offer inclusive computer science in
their school districts etc so i always
look at things as
there's always kind of that programmatic
you got to have
that programmatic success so that people
have confidence in you
while at the same time continuing to
build
scale and capacity right and i'm
imagining that
you know inherently if you're a tech
coalition within an area that needs
more you know understanding of of
of what the issue is and how and needs
you know perhaps assistance of
of meeting the talent needs that are
emerging
how do you find the communication with
the different vendors or the different
you know populations that you're working
with either whether whether it's the
education system whether it's the
corporates
whether it's the actual students do you
find that that people are speaking the
same language that everybody understands
what they need to do or or is there a
lot of
explaining that needs to be done here
um we've had to have conversations
around common language right and
and getting everybody with a common
understanding of that
but the whole idea of a coalition is
that
collectively we can do more than what we
can as individual organizations
that's why our members are involved in
literally shaping and prioritizing
everything we do but even to the point
we've brought together a re-skilling
collaborative
where you know frankly organizations
that you might consider
to be somewhat competitive in some cases
are we're actually working together to
look at what's best for an individual
and how can we funnel them into the
right
programs at the right time and so each
one of these whether it's higher
educations whether it's non-profits
whether it's reskilling providers
we have actually collaboration going on
in the region which is
so exciting to be able to move us
further
and so as you go throughout that journey
what has been
you know the biggest challenge you know
in this whole
you know it sounds like first it sounds
like it's very complex there's a lot of
different layers
there's the things that are very you
know open there's the things that are
more you know under the under the ground
that you and a lot of leg work that you
that you probably have to do there's a
lot of educating the market
on a lot of capacities since you've
entered your position i believe a year
and a half ago
what has sort of surprised you or has
been really challenging
that you know you're saying wow this is
really where where i really need to put
my my brains to
you know it's been really interesting in
each one of those areas you find
different things as you go through the
process i would say on the talent side
one of the things we learned is
do you think originally we only had k
through 20 and reskilling
and about mid last summer it's like okay
that's
all creating entry level talent but
where we have a gap is mid-level talent
so
attraction and retention became another
you know
layer to that data plays a huge role in
that right figuring out what skill sets
but every one of those areas you
continue to learn and i think it's
frankly we're an entrepreneur just like
everyone in your audience
right last year we set up a legal entity
we had initial programs we set strategy
all of that at the same time and just
like every entrepreneur
everything you do um you know frankly
gets
shaped along the way and we continue to
shape i don't see anything as being in
stone
but rather continuing to learn together
to move it forward
right and so if you're if you're looking
down the line
and you're looking at either the
milwaukee region or if you're looking at
people that are in similar position to
yours across the nation and i'm sure the
world i'm sure this is a problem that
many many regions are are facing what
insights have you gained
from this from from this experience you
know both from accenture and the masters
and
obviously ibm and now the milwaukee tab
cub coalition
what have you learned about this
ecosystem and talent
that you're saying i now understand this
better than i did
a while ago well i'd say
a couple of things um first of all
i think you as you said everyone is a
bit unique and so
i think one of the things you have to
say is what are we unique about
right and what's our unique value
proposition so
milwaukee is a very interesting place
it's a very
generous place people genuinely care
about one another
and so as a result both i think one of
our assets
as a region is we actually do
collaborate
and and help make one another successful
and and being very purposeful about that
but that took us a bit
right to learn that frankly about
ourselves
um to realize how do we take this 80 000
tech employee base and accelerate it
right
um and so that was one thing we learned
i think the other thing you know you
continue to learn is
just how critical right where all the
gaps are
and how critical these non-traditional
sources of talent are going to be to our
future
four-year degrees are great um you know
et cetera
i'm a big proponent of it so don't take
my comments wrong
but if if all we do is continue to hire
four-year degrees
our demographics of our tech workforce
will look almost identical to what it is
today
our pipeline looks demographically
almost
exactly like our workforce and so
therefore
looking at non-traditional routes into
talent um to gain talent
whether that's apprenticeship program
upskilling programs etc
are really a critical way to both gain a
capacity but also the diversity of
talent um that will help drive
innovation going forward into the future
that makes a lot of sense and and i'm
sure that you know
one of the things that i'm really
excited when i host these episodes is
hearing about people's passions and why
they do what they do and
and i have to say that you know just
from hearing you talk about you know
this problem and the way that you're
approaching this and the importance of
it i can see how
how excited you are about about where
you're at and the things that you're
doing and obviously you've chosen this
path i get so excited when people
get to choose what they spend their time
on especially when it's a meaningful
uh a problem transitioning from ibm to
accenture to now
to now this nonprofit i think it's just
great i have a few fun questions for you
if you're open to them
absolutely all right and i'm excited to
hear why why you're choosing the answers
you're choosing
we'll start off easy favorite subject in
middle or high school
okay so you did give me about two
minutes and i was like algebra which is
unique
and um and of psychology and and then i
started thinking about
well why and i think it's because i
really like patterns
i like figuring out the whys behind
things and the relationship
between different variables that's why
i'm so intrigued by
machine learning etc excuse me but
that's really worth that
wonderful all right somebody in your
life
that you know serves as either a role
model or somebody that just
inspires you a lot
um i would say my grandparents really
from an early age
um neither of them i am both
kind of salt of the earth people but
they were always very interested in
giving back
um to their community and they worked
extremely hard to provide good life for
their families etc but i think that
that value of hard work and
um and an ability to make something
happen if you're willing to give back i
think really came
out of my work with my grandma grandpa
by the way do you
was it was it hard to leave ibm after so
many years and and
and make this personal decision to
completely
almost change trajectories was it a
difficult decision
um it was a great decision and it was
very much
supported by ibm and and also by
accenture
um right because i had gone from ibm to
accenture and then here
and um you know i think when
people see passion like you did um i
think everyone's very happy for you
as you continue to your journey
wonderful all right
three words that you would use to
describe yourself and
why those three
so to make this would be one i don't
give up easily
on any particular thing
intensely curious that's probably
how i have managed um
you know to quickly learn tech despite a
non-tech background etc
and i guess um to determine was the
other one
that's kind of like tenacious but i
think all of those um go
together i love it i i love the the
the curious one i i i it comes up often
but i think that it really shines
through
people's decisions and their actions and
and and
it sounds like you know you didn't just
take on a different opportunity you went
to go study that opportunity you
followed your curiosity and now you're
coming and presenting that
in a place where you can really use it
to make a really strong impact kathy
thank you so so much for these 20
minutes i really appreciate it i learned
a ton and and i'm really excited to
share this with
with friends and family thank you for
being kind with your time i really
appreciate it
thank you very much michael
you